so
okay
you
oh
uh
let's make this
hey okay back there
hold up
okay
at some point
international
all right
oh
okay
okay
yeah but because of the gap over here
you
anymore
what
you
are you traveling
i think so i'm not sure
you are traveling i don't know yet
i think he's gonna go what's up
really he just got married he's been on
the ceiling is
degrees back in the back and you get
compensation
uh
uh
right
so
oh
it's a beautiful place
tomorrow good tomorrow
tomorrow
yes tomorrow for you've been delayed
little um
he didn't want to touch it
yes
by
hello
yes so it's not until like friday right
tomorrow so um
two minute warning
thanks
so
better chris yeah
so
much
good
is
no he's not going
it's pouring out
so
oh
yes
hello
um
what's up
hello everyone today president trump was
nominated for the nobel peace prize
in recognition of his work in brokering
an israel
united arab emirates peace deal was a
historic deal
and the first such deal in over two
decades
this is a hard-earned and well-deserved
honor for this president
president trump's foreign policy will
always be one
of peace through strength and that is
what the
american people are seeing abroad career
politicians merely talk about the kind
of results this president has achieved
on the world stage
end endless wars we hear that often not
too often do we see it actually done
today uh the president and the pentagon
the department of defense are announcing
a drawdown of troops in iraq
just announced from 5200 to 3 000.
we are getting our allies to pay their
fair share now nine nato countries are
meeting their two percent spending
obligations
we've secured better trade deals for the
american worker president trump
negotiated the usmca the u.s south korea
deal ended
the trans-pacific partnership brought
back manufacturing jobs
president trump has stood up to china
the phase one china deal
also tariffs told china accountable and
actions to block huawei
president trump's also defeated
terrorists the isis caliphate is
destroyed al-baghdadi
is no longer on the battlefield along
with iranian general solomoni
in addition to these priorities
president trump has made peace a
cornerstone of his recent foreign policy
efforts
the peace deal between israel and the
united arab emirates led to the first
flight from israel over saudi arabia's
airspace to the united arab emirates
the signing ceremony for this historic
deal will be september 15th at the white
house
president trump has also brokered
economic normalization
between serbia and kosovo a major
breakthrough
in this decades-old conflict it's a fact
president trump has broken the
39-year-old streak of american
presidents either starting a war or
bringing the united states into an
international armed conflict as a great
washington
examiner peace headline read these wins
are possible because of
the president's leadership and outsider
perspective
president trump addresses old challenges
with new solutions and delivers results
for the american people and with that
i'll take questions
paula haley thank you i'd like to ask
you about the woodward interviews
did president trump intentionally
mislead the american people about the
threat of covet
a pandemic that has now caused the lives
of nearly 200 000 americans
absolutely not um this president at a
time when you're facing insurmountable
challenges it's important to express
confidence it's important important to
express calm please play it down is
playing it down is that is that
expressing calm
it seems dishonest can you read the rest
of the clone that's how much they put
in there oh you excluded the last part
um
and he makes clear that he doesn't want
to see chaos by the way is the second
part of the quote which you failed to
read
um the president just days after having
this discussion um with bob woodward
said this from this podium on march 30th
he said
i do want them to stay calm we are doing
a great job if you look at the
individual statements they're all true
stay calm
it will go away but it's important to
stay calm so this president
does what leaders do good leaders it's
stay calm
and resolute at a time when you face an
insurmountable challenge that's what
this president hates it will not appear
that the president lied to the american
public about the threat posed by kovitz
the president has never lied to the
american public on covid the president's
been
very the president was expressing calm
and his actions reflect that
on january 6 the cdc issued a wuhan
travel notice before any confirmed u.s
cases
among another a number of other actions
and i'd refer you to dr falchi who said
that this president has an impressive
response
i can't imagine under any circumstance
that anyone could be doing anything more
that is the record of this president
john kelly but how do you how do you
square the president's words to woodward
when
he said this is a very delicate one it's
also
more deadly than even your strenuous flu
this is deadly stuff and then just two
weeks after he told woodward that
he said this is a flu this is like a flu
and of course he also said it was going
to quickly go to zero but that seems to
be in direct contradiction to what he
told woodward well the president was
listening to his medical experts because
you also have at the same time period dr
fauci who said this asking asked if the
seasonal flu was a bigger concern
he said this on february 17th so right
now at the same time
people are worrying about going to a
chinese restaurant the threat is that we
have in this country
we're having a pretty bad influenza
season particularly dangerous for our
children so he was reflecting that point
and again
days later in a briefing he said the
statements i made are this i want to
keep the country calm that is what
leaders do and that's what president
trump does
in that statement he's not comparing the
two he's not saying chronovirus is it
was like he was that was a cobit
interview and he was asked about
seasonal flu
vis-a-vis covid saying exactly what the
president said and in fact
the president was taking it more
seriously because on the tape he noted
uh that flu could be worse and he was
taking action to address it
once again context matters that zero
reported coveted cases the cdc was
implementing public health screenings
house dems were preparing to file their
first briefs and impeachment one
reported case
cdc um when their welford case the cdc
was activating an emergency operations
center while pelosi
was releasing a statement criticizing
mcconnell over impeachment
on january 31st the president issued a
travel ban
on china one that the former vice
president called xenophobic that's what
democrats were doing while this
president was
acting and his actions reflect the
seriousness with which he took coven 19.
yes you quoted dr fauci dr fauci is also
apparently on the record saying of
president trump that his attention span
is like a minus number and his sole
purpose is to get re-elected that's
according to veteran journalist bob
woodward
i think the bottom line here is that the
president by his own admission
in private on the record acknowledged
the depth of this crisis
and yet told the american people
something very different how is that at
its core
not an abject betrayal of the public
trust the president has always been
clear-eyed with the american people he
was always clear-eyed about the lives we
could lose
um again from this podium he
acknowledged that this was serious back
in march that
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
lives could be lost um
and with regard to dr falchi you're
referring to a quote he
allegedly told bob woodward and i can
give you quotes that we can all play on
loop and video of him saying that this
response was impressive
and he can't imagine anyone under any
circumstance doing anything better
uh dr fauci saying this i can just tell
you the president
the first and only time i went and said
you need to do mitigation strongly the
response was yes
we will do it the second time i went
with dr burks to the president
and said 15 days to slow the spread are
not enough we need to go to 30 days
obviously there were a lot of people who
had problems with that because of
potential secondary effects
nonetheless the president went with the
help recommendation so there's a long
litany of praise
from dr fauci and you're referencing
something he allegedly told bob woodward
it's it's on tape it's on tape daily
oh i'm reading i'm reading to you what
dr fauci has said very publicly for
all to see and we can all play those
video clips i can get them in your inbox
yes february 7th says deadly stuff about
coronavirus
in private on the record in public
though february 28th he says
one day it's like a miracle it will
disappear
it's one thing to as a as a public
figure not to try to incite
panic it's a very different thing
respectfully uh to lie and mislead the
american people
about a crisis that has claimed nearly
200 000 americans no one is blind to the
american people one day kovid
will go away i think we can all hope for
that day uh we will have a vaccine
because of this president
tearing through bureaucracy to get a
safe and effective vaccine one day it
will go away that is a fact
it is not inciting fear this president
has expressed calmness from this podium
mobilized the greatest mobilization of
the private sector since world war
ii uh got more tests than any country in
the world
on covid a vaccine which by the way will
be a record
for a novel pathogen the timing of this
vaccine should we get it by the end of
the year or should we get it even
three years which was the timing of
ebola this president
has done an unprecedented job dealing
with kovid and one that dr fauci even
acknowledged and like i said i will get
you that clip to your inbox
yes you mentioned a few minutes ago that
this was an insurmountable problem i
think
that's a quite a point of dispute if you
look around the world the united states
leads
the world in in confirmed cases in in
deaths
from 19. so doesn't the president have
their responsibility
for that record as well as the testing
and the vaccine development that you're
just talking about
now when you've looked at the rest of
the world um in particular the case
fatality rate in the united states is
about three percent
uh the world is 3.3 percent the uk 11.9
france 8.8 belgium 11.2 and um
you can go through the various western
world countries that have dealt with
covid
and we've done a very good job the case
fatality rate notes that and that's a
testament to our therapeutics that the
president has navigated us still
is still voting is the metric that shows
how well our response has done with
therapeutics and we are leading
the world um and having the lowest case
fatality rate it's a very important
metric and one that's a testament once
again
to a president who ripped through
barriers getting us from death severe
convalescent plasma
and other very good working therapeutics
mentioned the president
is very focused on the response there
then why did the president have
thousands of people
many not wearing masks that are at a
rally last night and what you know in a
state that has
limited outdoor gatherings to 50 people
why is he going to
nevada this this weekend to hold similar
outdoor rallies
uh uh the gathering these large numbers
of people in violation of his
administration's own guidance
and of the best advice and guidance of
local officials who he
said should have the final say in these
matters people have a first amendment
right if they so choose to show up and
express their
political opinion in the form of a
peaceful protest which is what
the president held and there's a real
double standard
here cnn had on a guest apparently a
doctor
rob davidson who said now true there are
social distancing issues with regard to
the protests we've seen around the
country
however this is a public health crisis
they are marching against systemic
racism so if you're allowed to march in
aggregate
um in those protests you're also allowed
to show up at a political rally
you have a first amendment right in this
country
um how can a president bear no
responsibility for the 200 almost 200
thousand lives left
lost when he downplayed the virus
initially
and he knew that how contagious and
deadly it was
i don't understand how that came the
president never downplayed the virus
once again
the president expressed calm uh the
president was serious about this when
democrats were pursuing
their sham impeachment uh he was
expressing calm and he was taking
early action and his actions are
reflective of how seriously
the tech that he took the language that
he used yeah you said
he used hopeful language does does he
regret that given where we are now no
this president
embodied the american spirit that when
we face a challenge
a crisis a pandemic we come together
we can be optimistic we can be serious
about it we can take it seriously with
our actions which is exactly what this
president
does it's why we lead the world in
testing i'm
doing far more than number two which is
india he
took this seriously but he still
expressed calm
our food supply chains were at risk that
we could not have mass funds on grocery
stores
uh the markets um also the economy was
in play here
we didn't want so there to be a huge
crash in panic he expressed
calmness from this podium but he has
always taken it seriously and the
response
and unprecedented response really
reflects that yes
so thanks kaylee um i wanted to ask you
about the
astrazeneca trial so does that throw a
spanner in the works that they've halted
those trials in terms of getting a
vaccine
quickly and and then i have a follow-up
yeah so the astrazeneca
um paused their trials um phase three
clinical trial
um was a routine response when the when
you see an adverse
um effect and it was one that shows that
the science is guiding the way here
um and when there was an adverse
response that was identified in one
individual
astrazeneca chose to pause that phase
three clinical trial there are still
two american vaccines in phase three
clinical trials showing great promise
um but you know astrazeneca what is
happening there showing that the science
is guiding the way on a vaccine which is
what dr
fauci um others like alex azar and the
president
have said all along you're still
confident that you'll see a vaccine
sort of before the end of the year by
the end of the year is the goal yes
so because there was some discussion
about seeing something around the time
of the election so do you think it
delays that
our timing is not about the election it
is about saving lives and by the end of
the year has always been our goal but
of course um a safe and effective
effective vaccine we will take it as
quickly as we can get it
so the customs and border protection was
supposed to be
announcing or said that they would
announce a ban on
and imports of many products from
shenyang province
in china uh as a result of the human
rights abuses
the uyghurs that announcement hasn't
come formally it was supposed to be
announced here at the white house are
you intending to make that announcement
or has there been
some backlash against just the breadth
of it
it does it does encompass quite a lot of
different products including
tomato products that you know yeah i i
have no upcoming announcements about how
we'll publicly um talk about that
discussion but if i get more information
i'll let you know
yes sure my understanding that the two
rallies this weekend in nevada have been
cancelled
because of governor siselek's order
preventing events of 50 people or more
does the president have a reaction and
what is the white house policy
about complying with the state's orders
limiting the size
of an event i have not heard that about
the rallies but i'd refer you to
the campaign for further information on
that but um as i discussed
with zeke here that we believe that if
people want to show up
and express their political views that's
their choice to do so we
hand out masks we encourage um
individuals to wear those masks a lot of
people did i was in north carolina last
night and saw it
we give out hand sanitizer but at the
end of the day if you want to join a
peaceful protest you can do so
um and there's no there's no reason just
like the protests we've seen in the
streets you can't show up and express
your political view at a rally
yes haley um can you give us some
understanding about why the president
agreed to sit down with bob woodward for
18 interviews when his first book about
the administration was so deeply
critical
because he's the most transparent
president in history okay so one more
follow-up
when um when do you expect that we'll
get the list the shortlist of who the
president is considering for the scotus
picks and what's the criteria that he's
using to assemble that list
yeah that's a good question um you'll
get that list in short order
um the president is very excited uh to
share
who he would nominate to the supreme
court
and what will guide on his choices are
people who follow the constitution he
wants constitution
abiding judges he wants textualists who
believe the words of the statue actually
are what they are
not subject to interpretation he wants
judges guided by the constitution
um judges and the ilk of the two that
he's nominated like justice kavanaugh
and gorsuch
yes thanks kelly um did the president or
anyone at the white house have
conversations with
the department of justice about their
decision to intervene in the evening
carol lawsuit
and if so what were the nature of those
conversations i'm not aware of any
discussions that have been hacked
the president has claimed he signed the
most favored nations executive order on
prescription drugs he mentioned this
again last night
um we haven't seen the text has he
actually signed the eo
and if so when will we and can you tell
us what the status of negotiations are
with pharma
yeah so the um the eo i believe he's
referring to there is the previous one
he's signed
a provision of that was most favored
nation
which means that for medicare programs
you have two ways to get prescriptions
part d
or part b part b are drugs you would
receive at the doctor's office
and the executive order tells the
secretary to peg prices for part
b to a most favored nation price to make
sure that american citizens are getting
uh their medications at a price equally
as cheap as other countries so that was
the initial eo i believe he was
referring to but any updates
i'll let you know in the upcoming days
yes
just in just following up on the uh
coronavirus issues how is it not
misleading
for his advisors to tell him
and compare this virus potential to the
spanish flu of 1918
but then for the president to say that
this could disappear by april
the president again was expressing calm
the president
um was hopeful that you know kovid um
would uh that we would be able to manage
this and handle it in a way that we
could make it go away as quickly as
possible and
the president rose to the occasion um
and did just that this was
a lot more i by the way it's worth
mentioning um
the misleading that the who in china did
on
this when you had the who they were
repeating
china's claim that the virus does not
transmit this was a novel virus no one
had seen and you have the world health
organization saying this vibrant virus
does not transmit
readily that is the information we were
getting
you had the white o'brien said that this
virus
could be the biggest threat to his
presidency uh
matt pottinger agreed with that
assessment and then president trump
would later
say that no one could have predicted
this when his
own experts were predicting this look
you're referring uh to the
intel community and they've what the
president knew was and i've walked you
through this before on january 23rd the
intel community briefed president trump
for the first time about covid and the
briefing said uh coronavirus from china
is poised to spread globally but the
good news is that it is not
deadly for most people this is the
information president trump
was getting and the next time he was
briefed on it was january 28th
when he was told that the spread was
happening outside of china and the
deaths remained all
inside china he was told then that china
is not sharing key data indeed china was
not
because as i noted to you on january 9th
the world health organization
said it does not readily transmit
between people and on january 14th
the world health organization said no
clear evidence of human to human
transmission clearly that was not true
even on february 29th as the virus was
spreading the who
put political correctness first by
opposing travel restrictions note that
on january 31st
president trump put into place those
travel restrictions that democrats
called
xenophobic shame on them yes
on the same day the president tweeted
that the virus would become weaker when
the weather started getting warmer he
told bob woodward it was going to be
deadly stuff
so why does bob woodward get the
president's unvarnished opinion when the
american people don't
the he was giving bob woodward the same
opinion he gave from the podium
and he said i'm here i want to express
calm that is what a leader
does he has always shared the facts he
has always been forthright
and he's always followed the advice of
his medical experts like dr fauci who
called his response
impressive yes said this was deadly
stuff yes
the american people yes he did he
acknowledged that hundreds of thousands
could die and he took the right response
which was to temporarily
shut down the country saved millions of
lives
and so too of his therapeutics so too
will the vaccine that's being developed
yes the protests in belarus continue
as well as the crackdown on the
opposition
what concrete steps the president is
going to take
to support uh belarusians in
their struggle for democracy and to stop
human rights abuses yeah it's another
very good question um the us is
extremely concerned by continued human
rights violations in the wake of
belarus's election
um reports of opposition figures being
kidnapped forcibly expelled
or otherwise threatened are just a few
of the many meth methods that the
belarusian government is using
in its attempts to deny freedom of
speech the u.s
is working with our international
partners to hold all of those committing
these abuses accountable
and we call on the belarusian government
to release all who are being unjustly
detained as for the election
the election there was not a real
election it was neither free
nor fair it was fraudulent the massive
number of belarusians protesting
peacefully makes clear that the
government can no longer ignore
the people's calls for democracy yes
caleb how's the president keeping his
promise of ending
endless wars if this announcement on
iraq is just
a draw down not a withdrawal there are
still troops in afghanistan saudi arabia
bahrain
they're still troops it's not really
keeping the 2016 promise is it
the president's drawing down our troops
these things take time
we want to ensure that the iraqi
security forces are well trained
and our u.s troops have done a
magnificent job doing just that we
believe
that now is the time when we can make
this draw down uh keep the country
stable
uh because of the training that our
troops have done so
we have an attempt to kind of try and
make it look like the promise is being
kept in events of the election
no not at all uh this is an expression
that we believe that iraqi security
forces
can do this alongside the troops that
will remain there um and the facts tell
the story that
this president broke the year old streak
of american presidents either starting a
war
or bringing the united states into an
international armed conflict so
unlike past presidents um this president
has prioritized peace through strength
which is his foreign
just on the breaking the 39th year
trend how does that work if
the president sent troops into saudi
arabia chanel
kaley thank you um with kosovo and
united arab emirates these are
muslim majority countries spanning two
continents now each
bringing some kind of agreement with
israel towards peace
um so my question is two points number
one
have the palestinians uh opened up any
kind of
discourse with the white house as to
their reaction
to these developments in it with israel
and middle eastern countries and number
two
have the palestinians actually expressed
any interest in
distancing themselves from iran in the
interests of middle east peace
through the deal president trump made
additional progress on reaching peace in
the middle east
kosovo and israel agreed to mutual
recognition
and normalization of ties and serbia
committed to moving its embassy to
jerusalem
only a few weeks after the historic
abraham accords between israel
in the united arab emirates this is
another huge step forward for broader
peace in the middle east
and the rest of the world i'd refer you
to the palestinians for their reaction
uh but it is quite telling that this
historic agreement between serbia
and kosovo addressing a decades long
conflict was only mentioned
one time on cnn and one time on msnbc
yes about the
winter olympics in beijing in 2022
more than 160 human rights groups have
called on the international
olympic committee chief to revoke the
gains from beijing
would president trump support an
american boycott
of the games over the chinese
regime's human rights abuses i haven't
spoken to him
specifically on that so i'd have to get
back to you
but this president has always held china
accountable his actions
very clearly show that he has stood up
uh to the
to china unlike any president before him
um in modern history but one thing um i
do want to address
is um just this really egregious
and i addressed it on friday but it's
worth um updating this
this atlantic uh story written by a
liberal activist
um now you have 25 people who have
spoken out
and dismissed this story and now you
even have
uh the author of the story who said
quote i share the view
that it's not good enough quote
referring to the fact
that he uh did this false report based
on anonymous sources
um and basically when you look at um the
liberal activist who wrote this
he has a very bad history um he can't be
trusted the left's new hero
used to be their number one enemy for
his role in the u.s entry
into iraq indeed in the early 2000s
this author was then at the new yorker
and he extensively wrote on the possible
links between iraq
and al qaeda a suggested link that was
key behind the decision of u.s
involvement in iraq
he relied on people who in her his words
quote
seem to me to be credible who said that
they had information about such
connections
between al qaeda and iraq and goldberg's
reporting simply backed up his view that
the u.s should invade iraq
um in slate in 2002 this author argued
in favor of the us
invading iraq and later he even admitted
that he knew people blamed him for
helping to get the us
into the war uh he wrote a sarcastic
piece saying yes
yes i know i started the iraq war
his reporting cannot be trusted as noted
by the fact that 25 people
have come out on the record dismissing
uh his report the report by a liberal
activist thank
call it a you
you